bonsoir de saison merci d'être avec nous
l'europe en quarts à demain comment vas
tu aimes va-t-elle être reçus je crois
que je vais très bien su parce que
d'abord monsieur erdogan a changé ton
depuis le début de l'année il ne fait
plus discours incendiaire voire
injurieux comme il le faisait auparavant
et puis les plus protégés par le
président des états unis pense que
monsieur by dunn a une attitude
différente que celle de son de son
prédécesseur il est aussi réaliste
l'union européenne reste le premier
partenaire économique de la turquie
elle est d'ailleurs en union douanière
avec l'union européenne cette turquie et
par conséquent monsieur erdogan à
redoute tout à fait d'éventuelles
sanctions qui serait très dommageable
pour l'économie turque
alors madame ursula von der leyen et
monsieur charles michel font le voyage
ils font l'effort en plein pour délit de
se rendre à ankara et je crois que le
président erdogan apprécié cette
démarche et que d'ailleurs à lui donne
l'occasion de montrer une certaine
autonomie de manoeuvre par rapport à
d'autres grands partenaires comme les
etats-unis la russie la chine l'iran ou
les pays arabes et il montre qu'il n'est
pas isolé
donc il a un intérêt important dans
cette affaire d'autant plus qu'il peut
évoquer avec les représentants de
l'union européenne l'émigration mais
aussi beaucoup d'autres sujets l'union
douanière les visas et beaucoup d'autres
sujets ils évoqueront probablement
demain alors évidemment demain les
sujets ça sera la question migratoire en
premier lieu que va demander le
président turc
le président turc va d'abord demandé
l'application complète de l'accord de
mars 2016 qui a donc cinq ans exactement
hoti haute aux termes de cet accord
l'union européenne
prométhée à la turquie 6 milliards
d'euros ce qui est considérable versée
en deux tranches et ses 6 milliards
devaient servir par l'intermédiaire d'un
certain nombre d'organismes qui n'était
pas le gouvernement turc notamment le
croissant rouge en liaison avec la croix
rouge internationale pour aider par
conséquent les enfants dénigrant à aller
à l'école et pour aider l'ensemble de
ces migrants a allait avoir des soins
ces migrants sont très nombreux puisque
il y actuellement en turquie 3 millions
600 mille syrien plus environ 450 mille
migrants venant d'afghanistan ou
d'ailleurs
mais je crois qu'il faut remarquer et on
ne dit pas encore suffisamment que un
grand nombre de ces migrants se sont
intégrés dans la société turque
c'est à dire qu'ils ne sont plus dans
les camps où il était à la frontière
syrienne
ils sont dans les villes turques et la
plupart d'entre eux ont cherché à un
emploi ou pour nous trouver souvent dans
le secteur informel
donc c'est très difficile de dire
exactement quel pourcentage mais se sont
installés et dans le fond très peu
d'entre eux ont l'intention de venir en
europe
ça n'est pas la même chose pour les
migrants afghans et pour ceux qui ne
venaient pas de syrie donc c'est la
première chose il va probablement dire
que cet accord n'a pas été totalement
respecté mais reste des sommes à verser
tout simplement parce que l'union
européenne raisonne en termes de crédits
d'engagement et madame ferraille n va
répéter demain que tous les engagements
ont été faits à hauteur de 6 milliards
d'euros
mais évidemment les crédits de paiement
qui sont ceux qui intéressent la turquie
son compte à un certain retard sur
l'engagement il faut conclure des
contrats avec des opérateurs et cela
prend peut prendre un certain temps
quelquefois plusieurs mois quelquefois
un an ou ou 18 mois et c'est ce retard
qui fait qu' il ya une dit
disparité entre les statistiques
bruxelloise bruxelloise et l'impression
de la turquie alors monsieur erdogan
vendre en répondra madame manderlay yade
s'est lui dit que après tout tous les
fonds ont été versés et veut dire on va
fait très bien et maintenant il faut
sans doute prolonger cet accord
c'est-à-dire conclure un deuxième accord
pour financer l'intégration des syriens
et de tous ces migrants dans l'économie
turque qui a été tout à fait
pratiquement mise à plat par la pandémie
de lakovic 19
elle était déjà en mauvais état
auparavant et la crise économique c'est
évidemment aggravé donc il va
probablement demander une aide
financière additionnelle
il va aussi demander d'autres choses
bien sûr il va demander de perfectionner
l'union douanière peut être mains de
reprendre la négociation d'adhésion à
l'issue de cette rencontre
la blanche maison peut-il y avoir selon
vous un rapprochement entre l'union
européenne et la turquie
peut-être mais ça va être difficile
compte tenu de l'attitude qu'a eu
monsieur erdogan au cours de la période
récente en fin d'année dernière
notamment compte tenu des mots qu'il a
employés contre certains chefs d'états
d'états membres de l'union européenne et
il est probable que s'il demande une
reprise de la négociation d'adhésion
c'est une négociation qui a été ouverte
il ya 20 ans on sape litres sur 36 ont
été ouverts bien sûr on pourrait
toujours faire semblant et dire qu'on
ouvre le 12e pour lui faire plaisir mais
je pense que même là dessus un certain
nombre d'états membres diront non
s'agissant de l'union douanière il va
demander un perfectionnement cette union
douanière une amélioration de la
fluidité des échanges entre la turquie
et l'union européenne
et là aussi il est bien possible que
lier des réticences de la part de
certains états membres
ainsi donc le volet financier est à dire
la négociation d'un nouvel accord qui
probablement d'ailleurs serait moins
important par son volume que la corde il
ya cinq ans puisque un certain nombre de
réfugiés s'intègre dans la société
dans la société turque et que finalement
ils jouent leur rôle c'était des syriens
assez souvent diplômés et qu'ils ont
trouvé leur place dans l'économie turque
alors par ailleurs évidemment d'autres
sujets peuvent être évoqués les
négociations avec la grèce qui vont sans
doute durer encore longtemps parce que
le sujet de la délimitation des plateaux
continentaux et est extrêmement
difficile et peut-être d'autres sujets
comme le retrait des mercenaires syrien
que la turquie avait envoyé en libye
il ne semble pas être totalement
effectué et puis peut-être d'autres
sujets qui seront soulevées d'un côté ou
de l'autre
alors ça veut dire que le dialogue sera
renouer et c'est une bonne chose ça veut
dire qu'il ya beaucoup de difficultés à
surmonter mais que peut-être que la
menace que leur disais aussi plané au
dessus de la tête de l'union européenne
à savoir que monsieur erdogan ouvre les
camps et lâche des milliers des
centaines de milliers de réfugiés
cette menace n'est peut-être pas aussi
réel qu'on le dit puisque encore une
fois il n'y a plus de camps et un
certain nombre de réfugiés sont dans les
villes turques inséré dans l'économie
dans l'économie turque
merci claude blanche maison